the left is very intimidating they've
got 61
of democrats believing that all
republicans are racists
that's and as i say republicans are
firing back by calling them liberals
or saying they're playing with politics
they're not playing people
at the height of the cold war david
horowitz was raised in a new york
communist household
at berkeley he led activism for
socialist revolution in the country
and then advanced as a prolific author
for the radical left in the 1960s and
70s
he was editor of ramparts the leading
magazine for the new left
he befriended huey newton and raised
money for the black panther party
his second book became a widespread
handbook for the growing anti-vietnam
war movement of the 1960s and then
after 10 years away from political
discourse david announced he was
supporting ronald reagan for president
and he was leaving the left we'll get
into what he witnessed that drove him
away from politics for a decade
and how he reemerged on the other side
of the aisle david's career originally
celebrated by intellectuals disappeared
from the cultural establishment almost
overnight
prior to conversion he had books praised
by major mainstream media publications
new york times la times the national
book awards and then was widely ignored
but david continued to be a prolific
writer
he used the anti-american beliefs and
experiences from his early life to
expose the damage to american society
from the left in this episode david
tells us about his advocation to fight
fire with fire when it comes to leftists
if the left makes politics without
rising to higher purpose with social
political activism
the right will never win unless we fight
that same way
and we discuss his latest book the enemy
within how a totalitarian movement is
destroying america
where david lays out how the democrat
party's actions have pushed us to the
brink of a one-party state
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show sunday special then shapiro
show is sponsored by expressive vpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben just a reminder we'll be doing some
bonus questions at the end with david
horowitz the only way to get access to
that part of the conversation is to
become a member
head on over to dailywire.com become a
member you'll have access to all of the
full conversations with every one
of our awesome guests david horowitz
thanks so much for joining the show
thanks for having me ben it's it's
actually an honor to be on with such a
warrior
for our country which is under attack
from within
i really appreciate that so we're going
to get to what is happening
in terms of your new book and and modern
politics in just a second but for folks
who really don't know your early work i
think it's important that folks know
your background
you started off as a full-fledged
communist essentially so maybe you can
explain
your transformation you started off in
actual commun communist family
yeah this book i've written the enemy
within
how a totalitarian movement is
destroying america
i is a book written from my own sort of
biography i was brought up by communists
i was one of the founders of the new
left
i edited its largest magazine
uh and i left the left when i realized
that it wasn't about
social justice it wasn't about peace
it was about hating and destroying
america
and this was brought home to me
when the left got its greatest victory
which was to drive america out of
vietnam
when the communists came in they
proceeded to slaughter two and a half
million
indo-chinese peasants and there was not
one single demonstration by the
so-called anti-war movement and i knew
then that
the my leftist friends didn't give a
damn about the vietnamese
they discussed the way they don't care
about black people or any minorities
what they care about is their hatred for
america
and destroying it from the foundations
up
so as you've talked about growing up in
a communist family you see a lot of
people now young people who are
resonating to the the messages of karl
marx and
of socialism and communism what is the
appeal i i don't think it's
predominantly an economic
appeal as much as it is sort of a an
almost spiritual appeal
it's a religious it's a crypto religion
they believe that the world is a corrupt
place uh
it used to be because of corporations
now it's corporations and white people
um and they believe that they're the
they're the redeemers
so they're going to act like gods that's
why they look i mean
why would you open the southern border
in the midst of a global pandemic
and let in a hundred thousand that's the
figure
corona virus carrier carriers uh
why would you abuse children on the
scale that
biden and harris or abusing them on the
southern
border if you cared about people uh
why would you be conflating black
criminals
uh with civil rights workers which is
what the black lives
matter movement is about and why would
you burn
cities you do it because you hate
america
and they put in a curriculum in our
schools that's backed by the biden
government the 1619 project it's a pack
of lies
that the idea is to make america's
founding
be slavery and racism
the 20 africans who were shipped to the
virginia colony in 1619
were not slaves and slavery was outlawed
in the virginia colony
and the virginia colony was not america
it was an english colony
that doesn't phase them from teaching
this to
k-12 students so the whole purpose
is to make them hate their own country
david one of the things that's really
interesting sort of about your life and
career is that you seem to have moved in
precisely the opposite direction that
the country has moved so you started off
as a communist when you were very young
and you moved through the new left you
edited rampart's
magazine and and now you're a member of
the of the right the country as a whole
started off as a conservative country in
the time that you were growing up it was
a country that very much opposed this
sort of fringe communist
radical movement and now as you
mentioned this has become the mainstream
in the united states the the
counterculture is now the culture and
the
and the culture is now the counter
culture how is it that the the arguments
that you were making
when you were young and that you grew
out of and realized were wrong how have
they gained such unbelievable cultural
purchase
first of all let me say you know if
you're being attacked by marxists they
always say you're selling out if you
move to the right
and in fact you know i would be the
subject of a hollywood movie
if i had stayed on the left and and
written by autobiography
uh it's seductive
it's not only their message is very
seductive we're going to help poor
people the vulnerable the least among us
all that baloney since their policies
are
hurting uh if you defund the police
who are the people who are you know
going to suffer the most
poor minorities in the inner city
that's their sole protection um
or you if you let violent criminals
run across the border and enter the
country who are they going to prey on
they're going to prey on his poor
hispanic people
they're not they're not going to go into
gated communities in beverly hills
so it's very seductive but also we have
a generation now or several generations
of complete ignoramuses
um i wrote the
the big problem we have is that
conservatives tend to be complacent
so it's live and let live that's a
conservative idea
so you know i wrote five books about the
communist takeover of the universities
and you know some of them got attention
but the republican party did nothing i
got no support from the
conservative movement you know to
protect academic freedom in the schools
and stop the indoctrination that was
going on
it's only now that people are beginning
to wake up so you have a whole
generation to have no idea what america
is about
that you know to them you know they've
been all brought up on the communist
howard zinn's uh people's history of
the united states uh they they think
you know the way they look at the
founding is it's a bunch of slave owners
and racists
when the opposite is true i mean
every black person in america always a
debt of gratitude to this country
for declaring for the first time in 3
000 years in 1776
that all men are created equal and have
a god-given right
to liberty and then within a little over
a generation
sacrificing 350 000 mainly white lives
to free the slaves when this they were
all enslaved
by black africans and sold at auctions
in africa
so you know the reality is that black
people enslaved each other
and white people liberated them but
to say that in today's climate what
makes me a racist
so david i think it's important here to
point out that your bona fides with
regard to to race
particularly of the left were pretty
sterling up until you made the move to
the right so you started off in
in solidarity with for example the black
panther party what was it
uh in your story for folks who don't
know that that drove you away from that
well the black panthers murdered a
friend of mine uh
i had raised a lot of money and bought a
baptist church in east oakland
and turned it into a learning center for
the panther children
and i believed our own propaganda so i
thought the state is racist
and if they don't keep their books
properly
i had created a tax exempt foundation to
fund this
school if they don't keep proper books
they'll be closed down i was completely
wrong i mean jesse jackson
and al sharpton have violated the
tax laws for half a century and
nobody's going to touch them because
they're black and leftist
um so i recruited my bookkeeper from
them
i i was editing ramparts the largest
magazine of the left
and i recruited her um to do the
bookkeeping for the school and in
december
1974 she disappeared she was
in a local bar and two blacks came in
and she left with them so she obviously
knew them
she was working for the panther party
and
uh five or six weeks later her body was
fished out of san francisco bay
and from my you know the police
interviewed me and they
explained a lot i've written about this
in a book called radical son
um i knew the panthers had killed her
and
uh that happened about simultaneously
when
the left was permitting was not
protesting the slaughter of two and a
half million
in no chinese peasants by by the
communists i knew that the left was evil
and i dedicated the rest of my life to
finding it
it said david let's talk for a second
about the the shift that we've seen over
the past
half century or more from the sort of
class-based argument that used to be
made by marxist to a pretty openly
race-based argument that is now made
by marxist it's a sort of fascinating
shift because obviously
marxism is class-based conflict the idea
is class solidarity
regardless of color and now that's been
transmuted into the
sort of intersectional racial
conflagration that we've seen where
instead of being a class-based conflict
it's supposed to be a race-based
conflict that
poor white appalachians are not in fact
poor and white they're privileged
and rich black people are not in fact
privileged they are black
and everything can be divided by race as
opposed to by class and yet somehow this
fits within the marxist
box how did that happen what does it
mean if you're looking for logic don't
look
don't look at a leftist
look marx was a crackpot everything that
he said of any importance
has been proven false over the last 150
years
we knew that the proletariat was not
going to be a revolutionary force
because they are if you remember well
you're too young to remember but the
hard hats
in the 60s the construction workers were
beating up
uh new leftists uh in their
when they did their marches um
so the the working class was not going
to make a revolution
uh and so it was it was natural to move
to
cultural marxism uh an italian communist
named antonio gramsci
came up with this theory um
that the the attack on the class system
was misplaced we should be attacking
leftists should be attacking the culture
and as it happened the vietnam war came
along
and the left didn't want to fight the
communists in vietnam so they
stayed in the universities and became
professors
and they made this the curriculum uh
cultural marxism is the menace that we
face today it's pure racism identity
politics it's also called
pure racism black people good
white people bad but of course it's not
all black people that are good
if they're conservatives then they're
raised right
traders but you know today's generations
don't have the
basic knowledge for example when i came
out of the left
um i i we we had been attacking america
um and when i saw how evil the left was
i took a second look at america
and i it was an ingenious
political system they created of checks
and balances
and what i described by new book the
enemy within is how the democrat party
you look at the democrat party over the
last decade
they are systematically destroying the
american political system
the system of checks and balances if you
pack the supreme court
you eliminate the independent judiciary
and legislators
not only appoint the supreme court
justices but they
they get to make any law they want
unconstitutional or not
they've attacked the voter id
this is racist the democrats claim that
poor black people are too
stupid to get a photo id
you can't get food stamps without a
photo id
you can't get welfare you can't get
prescription drugs you can't get into
the democrat convention
and if it were actually the case which
it's not since blacks are voting in
record numbers
that voter id was a problem the solution
is really simple
you set up a government agency to
provide photo ids to any american
who asks for one and deserves one that
is their citizens they're not dead
they haven't moved to another state the
democrats never propose this they just
want to eliminate voter id
because they are determined to create a
one-party state
which is the last sentence of my book
it's not about trump
it's not about winning one election it's
about establishing
a one-party state and the term for these
people
is fascists or communists it's the same
thing
that's the appropriate term for
nancy pelosi and uh and but in the biden
white house
they're they do what fascists do
they attack they demonize their
opponents
if you're a republican according to
nancy pelosi you're an enemy of the
state
how how much clearer do you need to hear
it from them
that they're fascists what happened on
january 6
reminds me of the reichstag fire
if you read trump's speech that he gave
on january
first of all trump asked in advance for
he offered to provide 10 000 troops to
guard
the capital on january 6th because he
knew it was a volatile situation
he was turned down deliberately by nancy
pelosi and the democrats so that
there were no troops there the speech he
gave
said uh this was a rigged election which
it obviously was
there's a rigged election uh we need to
challenge it
and we have these weak republicans who
won't have the
cohonies to challenge it so you've got
to go there and stiffen their spines
and if and do it peacefully he said and
patriotically
and if you fail what do you have to do
you must go home this is what he said
you must go home
and work to primary the weak republicans
in the next election you couldn't have a
clearer democratic voice
with a small d then pelosi not only said
that all
republicans are enemies of the state
but they they call this an armed
insurrection
they arrested something like 300 people
no arms not one arm was found
it was a it was a it was what the
the democrats have been calling a
peaceful protest
rowdy but basically peaceful they didn't
destroy a lot
they're charred the legal charges
against them
are trespassing and they're still in
jail
five months later they're still in jail
held without uh parole or whatever you
call
without bail um because the democrats
have this myth of an armed insurrection
that they want to use to create a
one-party state to so
demonize the opposition they call for
the expulsion
of senators holly and cruz for
questioning the election the democrats
have questioned
every republican victory in the national
election since
1980 including they have never accepted
as legitimate the trump presidency
so they're hypocrites they're liars but
the most important thing is that they're
fascists
why do i say the reichstag fire the
weimar republic was a democracy
hitler was elected chancellor
the first thing the nazis did was burn
their own capital which was the
reichstag
then they blamed it on a dutch communist
then
they passed the reichstag
fire act which criminalized their
opponents and set the foundations for
the third reich
and i know this sounds inflammatory but
it's dead-on
accurate to what's happening in our
country
if you you look now that the jews are
under attack from nazi
palestinian nazis who openly call for
the genocide of the jews the destruction
of the israel
and making it jew-free
eudenrein which is what the nazis called
it and you have in chicago yesterday
demonstrations from these nazi leftists
we have to start calling things by their
right names
the democrats call republicans enemies
of the state
armed insurrectionists traitors
white supremacists racists
and the mccarthy republicans are calling
them
liberals you can't win that battle as
long as we don't use the proper language
we're not going to be winning this
battle
and our country is at stake it's it's
fast going
it's eroding as we speak so david i want
to get into a little bit of the detail
of what you talked about there on
january 6th and some of the details that
you mentioned about the election so you
suggested that the election is rigged i
just wanted to dig a little deeper there
as to what you mean by that so i don't
see the evidence that
fraud and irregularity are responsible
for the vote outcome i've said that the
election was rigged by the media
that the media have obscured every
single fact in that election cycle that
the media
blacked out all coverage of hunter biden
for the last month of the election that
they lied openly about what was going on
with kovid they suggested that andrew
cuomo knew what he was doing but trump
was somehow at fault
for the vast wave of covid they
suggested that trump was a
vicious racist who was about to
establish a tyrannical government
despite
no evidence that tyranny was on the way
they suggested that he was a russian
cat's paw that basically
if you're talking about the sort of
informal rigging of an election the
media are the
the political communications arm of the
democratic party at this point and
that's enough to twist an election
uh when you say rigged the election what
exactly do you mean well
in my book the enemy within i described
what happened
in july uh of 2020 about what is that
six or seven
seven months out from the election the
democrats sent
600 lawyers and 10 000 volunteers into
the 50 states
to change the election laws so that it
would
to benefit themselves and what they did
was
unconstitutional for example in
pennsylvania
well first of all the constitution says
the election
laws are set up
by each individual state it's a
brilliant idea it decentralizes the
power
so the 50 state legislatures are
supposed to set the rules
in pennsylvania for example they changed
the law
so that the supreme court which was run
by the democrats
of pennsylvania they made the election
laws
and they did it in a way that
biased that there's about a million
4.4 votes
that were illegally cast because they
were cast in contravention
of the existing rules but with the new
rules set up by the democrat supreme
court
um here's the thing
nobody actually knows i i don't claim
that the uh the election was decided
by fraud i claim that there was massive
fraud committed during the election
we we cannot say for certain and
certainly the democrats when they accuse
anybody who questions the election of
treason are
talking through their hats because there
has been no audit
none of the election result and that's
because of the war the democrats
have conducted against every effort
to actually recount the votes and look
at what actually
happened trump got 10 million more votes
than he got the first time despite all
the slander of the media
biden couldn't hold a uh
demonstrating campaign from his basement
he's an advanced case of alzheimer's
everybody knows it
he's ah he's being manipulated as
president by somebody has to ask
permission
to answer reporters questions come on
this guy who couldn't assemble a crowd
of larger than 100 people
while trump was assembling crowds of 50
000 in little towns like butler
pennsylvania population
1240 and we're asked to believe
that joe biden got 16
million more votes than obama did at his
peak so any reasonable person and
there's so many other facts that have
come out about this but any and i've
listed them
a lot of them in in my book the enemy
within
um you you have to be smoking something
to think that that election is not
problematic
and basically that's what republicans
are saying that is
you know trump as he should as a as a
leader as the
the person who was de probably deprived
lets me put it that way of the depres
presidency but certainly the subject of
massive irregularities he has every
right to claim that it was fraudulent
but it's a claim the democrats have no
right to claim that there was no fraud
because that's just demonstrably a lie
so david when you talked about january
6th obviously the response by the
democrats to january 6th from my view
regardless of what you think of january
6 and i thought that it was a horrible
sight to see people
invading the capital um i thought that
you know the
the language of of insurrection uh was a
bizarre
use of the term considering that there
was no institutional support for
anything that was done there in fact the
election was certified
later that day by the same republicans
who are supposedly aiding in the
insurrection
cruz and holly voted to certify the
election that same day um
putting aside january 6th for a second
the authoritarian left's move
against freedom of speech in the
aftermath of that is the thing that
alarms me
significantly more than than 200 300
misguided people invading the capital in
defiance of what trump actually said
the fact is that they knocked parlor
offline uh they decided that they were
going to
start in the media openly militating for
the
for fox news to be removed from the air
uh they started suggesting that
advertisers needed to pull
from every single conservative oriented
show
and and then they started pushing
forward with with things like hr one
which is a comp
that actually is an attempt to rig
elections by federalizing all election
procedures up to including ballot
harvesting
they want to legislate what they
actually did in this last election
to federalize it is a tremendous blow at
the structure of our country which is
a federalist country we we have 50
states making election laws
so if you have one or two or three
corrupt states
you still have an election that's
got integrity mainly but if you put it
all in washington
and you put it in the hands of the
democrats forget it but they've been
waging
a war against the first amendment uh you
know since
trump's nomination actually before that
but certainly since trump's dominant
you know look to go back to where it
really started
they called bush hitler you can't
in a democracy if you demonize your
opponents
if you call them hitlerites um
it's the end you can't have a dialogue
they
they boycotted the trump presidency they
called him a white supremacist trump
was known to every american practically
for 30 years nobody ever
before he ran against a democrat nobody
ever
said introduced him as here's donald
trump
a host of the apprentice and a white
supremacist
that is to demonize and
silence all the opposition
that's not democratic and then and it's
it's like i said it's just
systematic the electoral college is the
same thing the
voter id the packing of the supreme
court they want to abolish the senate
um dingle charles i forget his first
name but he was the longest-serving
john dingle right longest-serving
congressman ever
last act was to write an article calling
for the
abolition of the senate and if you
listen to those media liars like
o'donnell if you listen to them
they say this that of course the senate
is undemocratic
wyoming with 500 000 people has two
senators and so does california with
whatever it is
40 million that was the idea
of the founding we are a republic we're
not
a one-person one-vote democracy
and there was a reason for that and it's
the founders were absolutely brilliant
they put sovereignty in the hands of the
people because they understand
that individuals can be corrupt
and therefore a monarch can be a very
dangerous
leader a ruler so they put sovereignty
in the hands of the people
but because actually as readers of the
judeo-christian bible they knew that the
problem
the so the problem the source of all
social problems is not race
it's not gender it's us
it's individuals people are corrupt
and therefore you have to put a check on
you know hitler was elected people
they the founders understood the danger
of pure democracy
so they put in this system of checks and
balances which
kids are not being taught anymore
they're just being taught about
imaginary white racism in school
and gender fluidity that that's that's
the curriculum now in our schools
but the founders understood the basic
problem is individuals and
and you know it's mind-boggling to me
because now
we have all these television programs
you know about murders on almost every
channel
you see how horrible people are
that's the problem how do you control
that
and the democrats are dismantling and
dedicated to dismantling the system
that has worked you know for 240 years
or whatever
however long we've been here so let's
talk about the democratic party so it
used to be that the democratic party was
the party of harry truman or the party
of scoop jackson or more recently the
party of joe lieberman to a certain
extent
and now they seem to have completely
lost their moorings nancy pelosi who was
a
fringe left-wing figure is now the
speaker of the house
chuck schumer who was a fringe left-wing
figure is now the senate
majority leader and joe biden who is
basically just an empty suit at this
point i mean they're just wheeling him
around
is is supposedly running the show but
it's fairly obvious that the democratic
party has become
extraordinarily radical and that the
radicals from the 1960s entered all the
halls of power so what happened to the
democratic party
yeah kavala harris grew up in a family
of marxists
bernie sanders is a lifelong supporter
of communist atrocities
as the head of the budget committee we
could go on and on
um i i've written this in several books
but where it started to go bad was at
the democrat convention in 1968
when tom hayden organized a riot
to destroy the electoral chances of
hubert humphrey who had been
lyndon johnson's vice president and was
the democrat nominee for president
they hated humphrey with a
95 ada liberal he was down the line
uh liberal leftist
but he was an anti-communist and that
was their sin
the left wanted the communists to win
the cold war
what can i say that's where the left is
they hate america
and they are either stupid
or blind they're blinded by their hatred
of america just the way they're blinded
by their hatred of trump
to see the reality of the threats that
face us
um after that riot humphrey lost the
election to nixon
and then tom hayden and jane fonda led
the left which had been
trying to burn down the country there
were many many bombings
in the late 60s and early 70s they led
these leftists who were trying to
destroy the country
into the democrat party during the
mcgovern campaign because
mcgovern had started with a you know the
pro-communist henry wallace that's where
he started his political career
um and the theme his theme of his
campaign was america come
home like we were the problem instead of
the solution
um and they created these leftist
caucuses the black caucus which is a
farrakhanite
racist caucus now a clyburn who
james clyburn who made
single-handedly almost uh biden the
nominee
is a farrakhan lover the most notorious
racist anti-semite semite
anti-gay bigot in the country louis
farrakhan who
from tehran has chanted death to america
uh clyburn is an admirer of his
um so over the next 50 years that
left infiltrated the democrat party and
they were helped by their control of the
universities
which has been now 30 30 years
and turning it into a marxist training
camp
our premier universities harvard yale et
cetera
princeton whatever um
they infiltrated the democrat party and
changed it um and their success came
with the election of barack obama
who has the same background i do he was
raised by communists
he was actually mentored by a soviet
agent
um and the difference between us is that
i saw that it was an evil movement
and wanted to warn people of the dangers
from it
and barack obama never left the
communists left
they made his career i've
written about this as well paul kanger
has written about it
uh stanley kurtz uh made
the communist left made barack obama's
career
and he didn't come out with the baloney
uh
you know that if she's neither left the
right
and we're all americans and all that
baloney um until he became a national
figure and that's when he distanced
himself
to save his skin from jeremiah wright
are raving
anti-american communists so there's
really no mystery about what's happened
to the democrat party
and the left is very intimidating
they've got 61
of democrats believing that all
republicans are racists
that's and as i say republicans are
firing back by calling them liberals
or saying they're playing with politics
they're not playing people
so david one of the things that has been
pursued obviously by the left is that
they do think in institutional terms the
right has a real problem thinking
in institutional terms probably because
for conservatives politics is really
about treating individuals
as individuals all of our all of our
political views are rooted in the idea
that you're supposed to treat
individuals individually with with as
human beings endowed with particular
rights
the left however is very focused on
taking over institutions and then
shaping
human beings from the top down uh
how does treating everybody as a as a
collectivity
just the way communists and nazis do
your group identity is more important
than who you
actually are as an individual this is
the most destructive
ideology you can imagine
and that's what they're about you know
joe biden one of the first things he
said and that this is the theme of his
administration
he said that uh systemic racism
touches every aspect of american life
that is a monstrous lie
worthy of xi jinping or of the
iranian mullahs or putin himself
there is no syste the only systemic
racism in america is affirmative action
and to get that through they they had to
get a pass from the supreme court
uh as a special case because systemic
racism
was outlawed in 1964
by the by the civil rights act it's
illegal
if there were actually systemic racism
and police departments across the
country
there would be a tsunami of lawsuits
wouldn't there
first they'd have to fire all those
black police chiefs
to have a semblance of reality but there
would be these
lawsuits that would be open and shut if
there was systemic racism there is
there are no such lawsuits because there
is no systemic racism
throughout the rest of america it's a
it's an invention
of a fascist party to destroy its
opposition
and establish a one-party state
that's what the democrats are about
that's the theme of my book
the enemy within how a totalitarian
movement is destroying america
how do you think that the right fights
back against this because again it's not
just from government
uh it's it's in academia it's in the
corporations i mean i think that the
right thought for
decades that the corporate world was
going to be free market oriented and it
turns out that now the corporate world
is
indoctrinating its own employees in the
same sort of critical race theory
that the universities were
indoctrinating their students with in
the late 1980s early 1990s
yeah because people respond to
demonization
and pressure they they head for the tall
grass
ceos of corporations don't want to lose
customers they're not brave people
it's an extortion racket when i came
into the
right 40 years ago the first thing i
said what
looked around and said was where's the
ground army
my ex-comrades on the left have
hundreds if not thousands of
organizations
whose business is threatening
politicians
and corporations uh intimidating them
uh you know jackson and sharpton made
careers out of racial extortion
you go to a beer company and say give us
10 million dollars
or we're going to call you racist and
boycott you
and that was told to me by a witness of
that happening bob
beckel uh not that he will say it
publicly
where are the where are the conservative
organizations grassroots
well donald trump has given the
conservative movement and the country a
great gift
because he has created the first mass
conservative movement in our history
it's clearly numbered in the millions
but just
if you just think of the hundreds of
thousands of people who turned out for
his campaign rallies
that's that that's the basic army that
can
uh save our country they get
conservatives need to get in the face of
these teachers
look what the teacher unions have done
they they've
damaged the lives of millions of k-12
kids because they don't they don't want
to teach they just want to collect their
paychecks
you've got to go in the face of the
teachers of the principles
of the school boards why isn't there a
sit-in
at twitter headquarters or facebook
making their lives
miserable and exposing to them
then press will flock to it and you can
tell the whole country what
sensors they are and what fascists they
are basically
uh and with hypocrites since we know
they let
iranian mullahs preach the death of
america on their
sites while banning the president of the
united states
i mean what greater act of censorship
is there than to de-platform the
president of the united states which
they've done
so what conservatives have to do is they
have to start being
more aggressive calling things by their
right names
use words like fascist when it's
fascistic
it's fascist it's racist
to demonize your opponents with no
evidence whatsoever
to call republica what happened on
january 6 an
armed insurrection is the way fascists
deploy politics
not you know americans
not small d democrats
they don't do that they're polite that's
what the collegiality is about
used to be in the congress
bipartisanship
how could you be bipartisan with a with
a party that you're
calling enemies of the state you can't
but no you know and it's true that the
media is
a bunch of liars they all what happened
to the media is that in the old days
uh reporters actually never went to
college
they went out on the streets and they
reported what they saw
but these journalism schools have been
corrupt for 30 years
you know i i i had lunch with the
chairman of the journalism department
there was a decent left
up center uh left a center person
um and i asked him i said michael d
do you have any conservatives on your
journalism faculty
he said i can't think of one i said do
you think that's a good idea for
training journalists or for
education in the first place not to
to have purged all conservatives he said
no i don't
i said what can you do about it he said
nothing because the professors
hire themselves and that's been going on
for 30 years i can tell you the columbia
school of journalism is the same way
nyu it's the same way all these elite
institutions are one-party states
the unit you know this better than
anyone been what one party states the
universities are
if a conservative appears on campus it
gets boycotted by professors
and the left comes into his event and
turns it into a circus
and the administrators think it's funny
so david let's talk a little bit about
you know how you got to be david horts
obviously now you're sort of
the the one of the grandfathers of the
modern conservative movement
um but again you started off in sort of
a communist family what was it like
growing up a communist
well i looking you know
i've had a pretty successful life so i i
can't
complain my parents were very decent
people i mean
i don't think my mother ever got a
traffic ticket but of course they hid
a an east german communist
in the basement whom the country was
trying to deport to port
so that they were part of a
conspiratorial movement and everything
everyone we knew
um and trusted was a communist as well
um it you know it gave me a passion for
social justice and then i had a rude
awakening
when i was editing that
ramparts magazine the largest magazine
of the new left
and the panthers murdered they not only
murdered this
mother of three children um
and threatened me but all my friends
said you know i would say i to my close
friends
like the panthers murdered betty
and they would say the white power
structure did it
which is the way leftists think they
think in terms of
anything that takes away individual
responsibilities
structures races classes
um and i i got an appreciation
it occurred to me i went into a serious
personal crisis
i was i think clinically depressed for
seven years after that
but in that crisis i try to rethink
everything uh including my attitude
towards america and what i saw was for
example
that that in america you had a figure
say like j
edgar hoover who
was an american hero i mean you know he
he was an icon and then there were
revelations about him
um his corruptions and so forth
and now nobody thinks of j edgar hoover
as an icon
anymore so i saw that you know you can't
prevent oil and justice
the world is an unjust place
but you can remedy some of the
injustices
within the american system the left
still thinks that the rosenberg spies
were innocent they never they never
reevaluate the left never looks back
and takes responsibility or the two and
a half million
peasants they cause to be slaughtered in
in no china you'll have leaders of the
democratic party boast about
being on the periphery of the so-called
anti-war movement to this day
so the left never gets to look at what
it does and i
you know the what's happened in a way is
the time
the time frame has collapsed so the left
now the democrats they don't see what
they did yesterday
like accusing the republicans of treason
for questioning election
when in the previous election
raskin who led the impeachment of
trump he was in the well of the house
protesting the certification of the
electors
in the trump election they don't seem to
remember what happened yesterday
let alone 20 years ago david how did
your parents become communists because
the your story really isn't just you
moving from communist to non-communist
it's it's almost a generational story
of of sorts i've written it i i wrote a
book called radical son which tells this
whole story but my
my father was a very weak person
and being a communist gave him strength
and you can see that with a lot of
airheads on the left these days
they you know without the ideology
uh okay uh ocasio-cortez
what would she be i mean she'd be a
bartender she's an airhead
uh and they're all so shallow
in the radical caucus in the democratic
house
um so the the joining this
and it's an international um
movement uh all over the world there are
totalitarians posing as communists or
fascists or islamic nazis
and they get a lot of power by doing it
they think they're changing
you hear them say all the time they're
on the right side of history
history doesn't have a side you know
uh the 20th century is probably one of
the worst centuries on record
in terms of human atrocities it's not
like there's
a a progression they love this phrase
that the arc of the universe has been
towards justice
no it's not it's not been in any way
that human beings can relate to
it just it is um so they get pumped up
i call it they get intoxicated you know
and it's all in genesis
we think adam and eve uh
were given paradise it was better than
the green new deal
you didn't die you didn't have pain in
childbirth you didn't have to work the
fruit fell from the trees but there was
one condition of staying there
and that was you did not do evil but
eating of the tree of the knowledge of
good and evil
is exactly what adam and eve did
and and who seduced them the devil and
what did the devil say
if you eat of that tree you shall be as
gods
and that's the way the left is
intoxicated it's intoxicated on its own
sense
of recreating the world how
arrogant and stupid is that
the world has been the same human beings
have acted the same way
for five thousand years you couldn't
read the iliad or the bible for that
matter
and recognize the people in it if if we
had changed
you know i mean after in genesis the
next story is about
the first crime brother killing brother
it's all there it hasn't changed and the
effort to change the world is what has
caused
over a hundred million people to be
killed
by progressives last hundred years or so
um and and what did they produce for all
those deaths
nothing totalitarian regimes
massive gulags where dissenters were
incarcerated and if you don't think
these democrats
are ready to put conservatives
in re-education camps you've got another
thing coming you haven't been listening
to what they've been saying
so david you were there for a lot of the
sort of seminal moments of the 1960s
particularly
from the perspective of the left you
were you were at berkeley
uh you were working at ramparts what was
it like from the inside because
everything has now been given this sort
of sepia tone i mean just in the last
year the oscars nominated two separate
films trying to recast the 1960s as a
as a time of wonder and joy there was a
full movie about the chicago seven
louding the chicago seven there's
another movie about the black panther
party louding the black panther party
what was it actually like on the inside
there there were two
um 60s movements one was the hippie
movement
which was i you know was relatively
benign except for all the people
who ended or ruined their lives on drugs
but the attitude was great flower power
and all that
um then there was the political movement
and there was a movement to rescue
communism from the taint it had received
when the khrushchev revealed that stalin
had killed so many communists
uh he left out the other victims but
the socialism was in bad odor then
and so the new left set out to redeem
the socialist fantasy but you can't
redeem it
if human beings set out to recreate the
word if they think they can
change the world look if you believed
that you could end
racism sexism homophobia poverty
war what lie would you not tell
what crime would you not commit or
support
to achieve that that's
that's why they are so immoral and evil
because they have a justification for
any crime
you can imagine and they you know
that they give even you know uh just to
bring it down to a
lurid level i mean how do you think that
harvey weinstein and
jeffrey epstein function in liberal
circles
it's because they don't give a damn
about human beings
they think they do it's all in their
heads
why would you defund the police who are
the only protection that inner city
minorities have why would you open the
southern border and let in all the
coronavirus
the carriers and the criminals and the
drug traffickers and the sex
traffickers and the child abusers
why would you do that because you have
this fantasy
that uh the reason we have borders is
because we're racists
and we can create a new world if we end
our racism
you know it's it's stupefying even to
try to repeat what they think so david
in just one second i want to ask what
sort of blowback you received when you
made the transition
to the right two things one is i lost
every for
every friend that i had in life from the
time i was
a kid every last one turned against me
because they they don't have human these
human connections
i just lost a friend of 70 years ron raj
who who wants to sick the irs on me
why because i questioned the election
result
70-year friendship thrown out um
over a political idea that's what
totalitarians do
that's what they are the ideas are more
important
than the human relationships uh the
second thing is
uh what peter and i had
peter collier and i we had run ramparts
together and we
transitioned out of the left together
and we wrote a
cover story for where the washington
post
which at the time which they
titled was their sunday magazine lefties
for reagan
our title was better run than red and
uh when that happened peter who was a
realist
i was much more of a romantic peter said
to me
our literary careers are over we had
been the toast of the town number one
bestseller for seven weeks on the new
york times list
wined and dined and attended by the
media
you know when we were attacked by the
ken it was a book about the kennedys by
the kennedys
the post considered us important enough
to assign woodward
um to examine the story and give us a
clean bill of
of health but peter turned to me when
our article
lefties for reagan appeared and said our
literary careers are over
and i thought he was nuts you know
but there was a lot of truth in that
uh i don't get reviewed in the new york
times or the washington post i used to
be front page
uh of the book sections don't get
reviewed
i'm an unperson i get slandered and i
can't
correct the slanders um
it just it all changed uh
i think things are getting better for
conservatives although
the censorship team is out there
in a big way but conservatives have now
created their own institutions when i
came into the right there were
not that many certainly no combat
institutions
no you know aggressive
conservative media institutions that's
all changed uh
conservatives are now in the culture and
fighting in the culture and that's great
so david i was going to ask you a little
bit earlier about you know whether
there is any hope coming from sort of
center and people who are who are actual
liberals you know people who may
disagree
with you or with me on tax rates uh or
may disagree on the role of government
and healthcare
but still are fundamentally committed to
certain basic individual liberty
principles
it seems like an open question to me so
i wanted to get your take on it
they are collected on substack.com
but like glenn greenwood just to
you know tear into me and call me all
kinds of names
and i recently emailed him and said i
have to say even though
you said harsh things about me i admire
your courage uh and determination to
you know fight for our individual
liberties he's been a
a warrior on that front matt to eb
who i wrote a whole book ridiculing
trump
uh has also been i mean he he wrote an
article called the permanent coup
about what the democrats were doing to
trump even though he
doesn't think much of trump so those are
two
and you know jonathan turley has been
pretty good
on legal issues and alan dershowitz
um you know both of them democrats
uh but they're small voices
in the you know or few voices because
dershowitz has a big voice and so does
turley
but there aren't a lot i mean it's very
disappointing i
i think that you know if you're thinking
of elected officials most of them are
intimidated
pelosi is ruthless and will destroy
their careers
um but i i can't believe that
if democrats are confronted
you know if they if if there are two
sides to a question that they won't be
shaken
there have got to be some good democrats
out there i'm not talking about the
voters who
are not aware of most of these issues
i'm talking about the leaders but it's
very disappointing not to have a
democrat
stand up and condemn the
impeachments of trump black lives matter
called january 6
a white supremacist coup
you you know if you listen even to these
people
uh patrice calor is the co-founder of
black lives matter is a sociopath just
read her biography
she's a sociopath and a racist
and and you know a defender of criminals
they lie about
but you know i you don't have to
actually do a lot of research you just
look what happened in ohio when that cop
saved the life of a black teen
who was in the process of being stabbed
to death by
another black who said i'm going to
effing stab you to death that's on
video and they call the cop a murderer
because he's white
and the murderer he killed is black
these are disgusting people black lives
matter
you know jason whitlock has said it's
the ku klux klan
jason whitlock is a black brilliant
sports commentator
but that that's what it is so david in a
second i want to ask you a few final
questions
i want to talk with you particularly
about sort of your spiritual journey
because you've moved
uh in in sort of an interesting
direction spiritually over the course of
your career if you'd like to hear david
horowitz's answers you have to be a
daily wire member
head on over to dailywire.com click
subscribe you can hear the rest of our
conversation
over there well everybody make sure to
go out and get a copy of david's brand
new book the enemy within how a
totalitarian movement is destroying
america david
thanks so much for joining the show
really appreciate it thanks for having
me ben
the ben shapiro show sunday's special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavo widowski
our guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
title graphics are by cynthia angulo the
ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
[Music]
you